[Musik]
tokio
bahnhof shinjuku einer der
verkehrsreichsten der welt jeden tag
sind hier mehr als drei millionen
fahrgäste unterwegs damit das
reibungslos funktioniert ist alles
perfekt organisiert
[Musik]
dieser bahnhof schläft nicht ob tag oder
nacht hier herrscht immer hochbetrieb
sie haben nur drei stunden wir müssen
schnell arbeiten
die logistik in der diesen enormen
verkehrsknotenpunkt erfordert absolute
präzision und ständige kontrolle in
jeder situation
wir überwachen alles 24 stunden am tag
fünf verschiedene bahngesellschaften
fast 3000 fahrgäste pro minute
zug einfahren im sekundentakt dieses
komplexe uhrwerk am laufen zu halten ist
eine anspruchsvolle aufgabe
[Musik]
tokio die größte metropole der welt mit
fast 40 millionen einwohnern
rund ein viertel von ihnen wohnt im
zentrum der stadt
dazu kommen rund elf millionen pendler
besucher und touristen
diese menschenmassen zu koordinieren ist
jeden tag aufs neue eine herausforderung
durch japan verlaufen insgesamt gut
24.000 kilometer schienen ein drittel
davon allein in der metropolregion tokio
und die meisten schienen führen hier er
zum bahnhof shin schoko benannt nach dem
bezirk in dem er liegt
der bahnhof erstreckt sich einen
kilometer weit durch den stadtteil
mitten im zentrum tokios
dieser gigantische verkehrsknotenpunkt
ist ein komplexes netzwerk verschiedener
bahn u bahn und buslinien
der bahnhof hat fünf haupt ebenen und
insgesamt 20 bahnsteige
dort kommen züge fünf verschiedener
bahnbetreiber an
der u bahn linien verbinden den bahnhof
außerdem mit dem tokioter
nahverkehrssystem
[Musik]
am busterminal werden 1600 fern
busverbindungen abgefertigt
der bahnhof shin schoko ist eine eigene
stadt innerhalb der stadt mit geschäften
büros und restaurants
[Musik]
es ist früh am morgen
die 200 eingänge der riesen station
öffnen sich nach und nach zwischen 415
und 7 uhr
pendler reisende auf dem weg zum
flughafen und nach teuren unterwegs nach
hause warten bereits auf den ersten zug
um 4 30
[Musik]
um 10 nach 5 setzt sich das erste
rolltor zum geschäftigsten teil des
bahnhofs in bewegung
damit beginnt die heutige rush hour und
sie wird erst am späten abend wieder
enden
[Musik]
immer mehr fahrgäste strömen in den
bahnhof
mit öffnung der eingänge beginnt auch in
den dahinter liegenden geschäften der
tag cafés kioske kleine frühstück ab
sie alle wappnen sich für den
bevorstehenden ansturm
wie jeden tag erwarten sie auch heute
3,6 millionen bahnreisende das
entspricht der gesamtbevölkerung berlin
[Musik]
pro stunde waren sich nun
durchschnittlich 200.000 menschen ihren
weg über die kilometer langen strecken
zwischen bussen u bahnen und zügen
die hallen und gänge dieses bahnhofs der
superlative werden bis zum einbruch der
nacht vor reisenden nur so wimmeln
von einem zum anderen ende zu laufen
dauert 45 minuten und zwar auf dem
kürzesten weg
70 24
im morgendlichen betrieb müssen alle
abläufe sitzen
die passagiere bekommen nicht viel davon
mit
einer von ihnen ist eiki khurana
fast jeden tag um diese uhrzeit ist er
unterwegs zum bahnhof shinjuku
der bahnhof ist sehr groß und spielt für
mich und viele andere eine wichtige
rolle
ich fahre jeden tag hier ab
es ist mein lieblings bahnhof in tokio
[Musik]
gewann schätzt all die annehmlichkeiten
im bahnhof
auch wenn hier im moment jede menge los
ist
[Musik]
sein erster weg führt ihn zu dem gepäck
stets sicher hier schließt er seinen
rucksack
nicht nur für schwer beladene touristen
sind sie ein segen sondern auch für die
tokioter selbst
und das ist kein wunder
japanische angestellte leisten
durchschnittlich fast 4 überstunden pro
tag danach geht es weiter zu
teambildenden veranstaltungen
sogenannten omega die grenze zwischen
arbeit und freizeit ist fließt daher
nutzen viele japaner die zentral
gelegenen schließfächer am bahnhof um
ihre freizeitkleidung zwischenzulagern
wie es in japan üblich ist wird service
auch am bahnhof shinjuku groß
geschrieben auch beim fahrkarten system
satori kubaner kann sein ticket
jederzeit auflagen
[Musik]
man kann die karte aufladen und damit
verschiedene linien nutzen zb die
kiellinie die order juli mo und alle
linien
man muss die karte einfach nur davor
halten und kann jeden zug nehmen sonst
wäre das eher schwierig
eine fahrkarte für alle linien
so erleichtert man den fahrgästen das
leben und vermeidet unnötige wartezeiten
wegen eines komplizierten bezahlsystems
und an auswahl herrscht kein mangel der
bahnhof wird von fünf verschiedenen
bahngesellschaften angesteuert
die größte von ihnen ist
daneben gibt es noch auf der tokio tokio
metro und die tuba mit 16 linien
transportiert allein ist jeden tag
anderthalb millionen fahrgäste
das entspricht 80 prozent des gesamten
schienenverkehrs in der stadt
die fahrgäste müssen ihr elektronisches
ticket nur alle zehn jahre erneuern ein
bedeutender faktor in den bemühungen mit
den menschenmassen fertig zu werden die
jeden tag in den bahnhof shinjuku
strömen
[Musik]
mindestens ebenso wichtig ist dass aus
fehlern zu lernen lange zeit führten
endlose schlangen an ticketschaltern und
dauer gestresste angestellte zu chaos
bei einer umfangreichen modernisierung
im jahr 2012 wurden dann standardisierte
chipkarten für den gesamten tokioter
nahverkehr eingeführt
seither ist es war einfacher als ich im
ticket system zurecht zu finden aber
sich im bahnhof selbst zu orientieren
ist immer noch eine enorme
herausforderung
ich bin jeden tag hier daher kenne ich
mich aus aber wer mit dem bahnhof nicht
vertraut ist kann sich leicht verlaufen
dann sollte man sich an den wegweisern
orientieren um sich zurechtzufinden sie
zeigen wie man zum beispiel zur ort der
kiellinie oder den linien kommt
im schlimmsten fall kann einmal falsch
abbiegen zu einem kilometerlangen umweg
führen
die beschilderung folgt einen
ausgeklügelten denn auch nicht
unkomplizierten system
zunächst einmal wurde jeder hauptlinie
eine feste kämpfe zu genießen
grün steht beispielsweise für die
jammern oder linie und führt zu den
bahnsteigen 14 und 15
und dann wäre da noch die buchstaben und
zahlen sie weisen den weg zu den
verschiedenen ein und aus ging
neben den süd ost und west
haupteingängen gibt es noch dutzende
andere auf den ersten blick ist das
ganze ziemlich unübersichtlich
[Musik]
sich hier zurechtzufinden ist vor allem
für touristen und ausländer ohne
japanisch kenntnisse schwierig
jeden tag wird der twitter account des
bahnhofs von beschwerden geflutet weil
fahrgäste nicht zum richtigen gleis
gefunden haben
[Musik]
aber wen wunder dass bei 200
verschiedenen ein und ausgängen auf rund
einem kilometer
und der bahnhof shin schoko wächst immer
weiter
[Musik]
architekt kiesow kitamura analysiert den
verkehrsknotenpunkt seit jahren er und
seine studenten beobachten das
kontinuierliche wachstum des bahnhofs
tamora hat sogar ein eigenes 3d modell
angefertigt um die probleme zu
untersuchen die dadurch verursacht
werden
[Musik]
es gibt viele gründe warum sich menschen
nicht in diesem bahnhof zurechtfinden
zunächst einmal werden ständig
bauarbeiten durchgeführt es gibt neue
geschäfte und neue wege so dass alles
ständig anders aussieht und sich die
leute verlaufen
das gilt vor allem für jene die sich auf
ihr gedächtnis verlassen denn sie achten
nicht auf die wegweiser
der bahnhof shinjuku war schon immer
eine dauerbaustelle
ganz besonders in den goldenen 60ern wie
sie in japan bezeichnet werden während
dieser zeit wuchs die japanische
wirtschaft rasant und mit ihr logistisch
verbindungs und knotenpunkte
am anfang war jede menge platz so
konnten sie die gleise nebeneinander
verlegen sie bauten zunächst einen
bahnsteig und dann immer mehr
aber der schienenverkehr nahm zu und der
platz im stadtteil shinjuku wurde knapp
darum legten sie unterirdische strecken
an und bauten immer mehr stockwerke in
die tiefe
das zeichnet den bahnhof shinjuku aus
es dauerte jahrzehnte bis der bahnhof so
bedeutend wurde wie er es heute ist
als er 1885 eröffnet wurde war die
gegend noch ein ruhiges wohngebiet erst
allmählich stellte sich das wachstum ein
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde der
stadtteil tokios geschäfts und
verwaltungszentrum plötzlich war der
bahnhof der wichtigste
verkehrsknotenpunkt der stadt
verblüffenderweise ist der riesige
bahnhof von außen kaum als solcher zu
erkennen
ein krasser gegensatz zu den anderen
ortsüblichen pompösen gebäuden
er verschwindet förmlich zwischen den
umliegenden einkaufszentrum
auch das hat tradition in der
japanischen kultur
funktionalität und effizienz stehen
immer an erster stelle
und noch etwas erschwert zumindest
auseinander die orientierung trotz aller
modernität sind viele schilder nur auf
japanisch gehalten englisch ist
hierzulande bis heute nicht allzu
verbreitet
aber amiga bahnhof gibt man sich mühe
dieses problem zu lösen
informationsschalter gibt es in
praktisch allen großen bahnhöfen aber
entschied schoko sind sie unverzichtbar
man findet sie an allen haupteingängen
zusätzlich sind zahlreiche helfer im
gesamten gebäude unterwegs
einer dieser angestellten die den
fahrgästen helfend zur seite stehen ist
joshua caravan
er unterstützt reisende dabei an ihr
ziel zu gelangen
gleichzeitig sorgt er dafür dass ich
während der nie endenden rushhour keine
allzu lange schlangen bilden die
fahrgäste halten ihn und seine kollegen
den ganzen tag dann auf trab
als ich hier angefangen habe war ich
schockiert wie viele leute unsere hilfe
brauchen wir wurden alle möglichen
fragen gestellt das ist eine echte
herausforderung
per ass awer und seine kollegen sollen
den fahrgästen vermitteln dass sie
jederzeit unterstützung bekommen können
für angestellte ist das
kundenfreundliche image des riesen
bahnhofs mehr oder weniger heilig
[Musik]
ich muss jederzeit sichtbar sein damit
die leute wissen dass sie mich
ansprechen können darum trage ich auch
immer diese armbinde
an manchen tagen hat karas aber mit bis
zu 20 verschiedenen nationalitäten zu
tun sein ziel ist es sie alle mit
informationen in ihrer jeweiligen
landessprache zu versorgen aber trotz
aller bemühungen braucht auch er
manchmal hilfe sein tablet übersetzt
blitzschnell fragen und antworten
[Musik]
er selbst muss sich im bahnhof natürlich
im schlag zurechtfinden können
[Musik]
servicemitarbeiter in einem der
verkehrsreichsten bahnhöfe der welt für
diesen job braucht man leidenschaft es
wenn ein kunde dankeschön sagt ist das
mein größter lohn dann will ich mir noch
mehr mühe geben
selbst erfahrene ortskundige fahrgäste
vertrauen manchmal mehr auf kazaa was
experten wissen als auf ihren eigenen
orientierungssinn
guten tag ich möchte zum bahnhof asuka
wo muss ich da lang
nehmen sie die schuhe linie auf gleis 8
und steigen sie am bahnhof kann darum
danke
dienstbeflissen freundlich effizienz
diese klischees von japanern sind sehr
verbreitet hier am bahnhof shin schoko
sieht man warum
viele fragen die servicemitarbeiter weil
das viel einfacher ist als er selbst
herauszufinden sie wissen immer den
besten und schnellsten weg
[Musik]
im tokioter bezirk liegt einer der
geschäftigsten bahnhöfe der welt hier
zählt vor allem eins öffentlichkeit die
züge der größten bahn gesellschaft sind
durchschnittlich nur erstaunliche 24
sekunden verspätet bei verspätungen ab
fünf minuten bittet der schaffner über
lautsprecher an gleis um verzeihung
natürlich mit größtmöglicher höflichkeit
[Musik]
pünktlich und präzise diesen ruf wollen
die bahnangestellten nicht aufs spiel
setzen disziplin ist gleichbedeutend mit
stolz und ehre das gilt auch für 9
darum hätten jeden morgen die
wichtigsten regeln des jobs
durchexerziert
[Musik]
im bahnhof steht ein ausländisch
aussehende fahrgast der sich umsieht und
orientierungslos wirkt was tun sie
ich frage verzeihen sie bitte kann ich
ihnen behilflich sein um eine
unterstützung anzubieten
berufsanfänger kokain o träumt davon
eines tages zugführer zu werden
um ins führerhäuschen zu gelangen müssen
die auszubildenden eine harte schule
durchlaufen und natürlich lernen was
absolute priorität hat zufriedene
fahrgäste
gut jetzt übernehmen die erfahreneren
machen sie bitte weiter
ein lächeln für die kunden
gut uhren vergleich okay an die arbeit
[Musik]
die uno ist heute dafür eingeteilt den
bahnsteig zu beaufsichtigen eine äußerst
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
regel nummer eins haltet die schienen
frei und den bahnsteig unter kontrolle
dazu hält sich geno stets an strikte
japanische regeln
das system funktioniert
tokios größte bahngesellschaft
verzeichnet jährlich weniger als 200
unfälle
und sie investiert umgerechnet mehr als
18 milliarden euro pro jahr in
sicherheitsmaßnahmen
ziel ist es die anzahl mit
personenschäden zukünftig auf null zu
verringern
ein ehrgeiziges ziel
und kino ist stolz zu dessen erreichen
beitrag zu kommen ja keine fehler zu
machen setzte ich die arme mit ein so
bin ich konzentrierter
okay okay
die i-know erfüllt seine aufgabe
gewissenhaft egal ob am bahnsteig gerade
zwei oder 200 fahrgäste stehen
einmal ist ein kunde auf die schienen
gestürzt glücklicherweise habe ich es
gesehen in solchen situationen ist es
gut dass sich alles genau überprüfen
darum müssen wir die abläufe strikt
einhalten
kaum unfälle mit personenschäden so gut
wie keine verspäteten züge absolute
perfektion natürlich steht ihm diese
schlacht nicht allein
in sachen sicherheit setzt der mega
bahnhof auch auf überwachungskameras
davon gibt es hier sehr sehr viele
[Musik]
und hier laufen alle bilder zusammen im
kontrollraum des bahnhofs leiters er und
sein team haben jederzeit alles im blick
als tagungsleiter trägt hätte iq
moriyama großer verantwortung
[Musik]
ich bin für den gesamten bahnhof
zuständig und muss mich mit allen
bahnhöfen in der umgebung am stimmen
der bahnhof shinjuku muss als
hauptbahnhof im bezirk auch deren
fahrpläne im blick behalten
meine drei hauptaufgaben gebiete sind
sicherheit pünktlicher züge und dafür zu
sorgen dass die 380 angestellten des
bahnhofs das ganze jahr über gut
zusammenarbeiten
ein großes problem ist dass es in der
gegend noch andere bahnhöfe gibt wie den
bahnhof die jugend
der nur 800 meter entfernt liegen
verspätungen lassen sich auf so einer
kurzen strecke natürlich nicht aufholen
die bahnhöfe müssen eng zusammenarbeiten
und ihre fahrpläne genau abstimmen nur
so lassen sich verspätungen und auch
unfälle auf ein minimum reduzieren
wir können uns außerdem und jegliche
zwischenfälle wenn ein fahrgast
medizinische hilfe braucht oder wenn
sich etwas verdächtiges im
bahnhofsbereich abspielt die
informationen laufen hier zusammen und
wir reagieren dann entsprechend die
zentrale ist 24 stunden am tag besetzt
moriyama und sein team sind die augen
und ohren des bahnhofs
dank modernster technologie erhalten sie
trotz der enormen größe des
verkehrsknotenpunktes immer den
überblick
[Musik]
im bahnhof selbst herrscher morgen
hochbetrieb vor allem in den geschäften
ist jetzt viel los die kassen klingen zu
den stoßzeiten hat jeder laden stündlich
rund 200 kunden
japans private bahngesellschaften nutzen
ihre liegenschaften für
unterschiedlichste zwecke neben den
bahnhöfen richten sie dort auch
einkaufszentren bürokomplexe
reiseagenturen oder supermärkte ein
das gesamte gebiet im und um den bahnhof
shin schoko ist auf umsatz ausgelegt
damit das alles so rund wie möglich
läuft hat höchstmögliche
kundenfreundlichkeit hier absolute
priorität
die fahrgäste können die einkäufer sogar
mit ihrem zug ticket bezahlen
tatsächlich ist dieser riesige
verkehrsknotenpunkt sehr viel mehr als
nur ein bahnhof
kaum ein pendler könnte sich in choco
ohne diese geschäfte vorstellen die
bento box leben meistens direkt auf den
weg zu den bahnsteigen gelegen
viele fahrgäste täglich hier einen stopp
ein bevor sie ihre reise fortsetzen
im moment ist noch alles friedlich aber
hast geh ja madeira arbeitet lange genug
hier um zu wissen das ist nur die ruhe
vor dem sturm
[Musik]
gleich wird es hier voll dann fährt ein
viel genutzter zug ab und es kommen eine
menge leute rein also brauchen wir viele
lunchboxen um das pensum zu bewältigen
müssen wir als team zusammenarbeiten
jeden tag werden in der küche vor allem
fisch und gemüse frisch vor dem ersten
kundenansturm zubereitet
an guten tagen gehen hier 2.500 bento
boxen über die ladentheke
japanern ist gutes und frisches essen
sehr wichtig auch auf reisen
gewürze und fett werden nur sparsam
eingesetzt für die kunden zählt der
eigengeschmack der lebensmittel
verkauft sich jährige mäßig eine bento
box
traditionell ist darin reis als
hauptbestandteil enthalten dazu kommen
verschiedene gemüse fleisch oder fisch
toppings
je nach variante kosten die boxen
umgerechnet zwischen vier und acht euro
[Musik]
um an den bahnsteig zu gelangen müssen
die täglich mehr als dreieinhalb
millionen fahrgäste einer von 104
vollautomatischen zugangskontroll
anlagen passieren
der bahnhof shin schoko wird täglich von
genauso vielen fahrgästen genutzt wie
das gesamte londoner u bahn netz und
dennoch ist von chaos keine spur
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hmm
[Musik]
alle stimmen ordentlich an im moment
herrscht hochbetrieb aber dass sich alle
an die regeln halten und anstehen wird
er es gar nicht so voll und
das gilt an allen bahnsteigen und für
alle züge sei es über oder unterirdisch
das wichtigste hilfsmittel dabei sind
die markierungen am boden jeder zug hält
an einer ganz bestimmten stelle
dort stehen die wartenden fahrgäste
geduldig und zwar so dass sie den
aussteigenden passagieren nicht im weg
sind
da sich japaner gewöhnlich an regeln
halten kann der fußverkehr ungestört
fließen
es steigen sogar gleichzeitig fahrgäste
ein- und ochs
[Musik]
die türen öffnen und schließen sich
automatisch innerhalb eines festgelegten
zeitfensters
so dauert das aus und einsteigen nicht
einmal eine minute und der zug kann
pünktlich abfahren
[Musik]
doch das war nicht immer so lange zeit
war der bahnhof shin schoko für seine so
genannten bürger bekannt die dafür
sorgten dass der fahrplan eingehalten
wurde ihre aufgabe war es fahrgäste in
die vollen waggons hinein zu drücken
weit weniger zivilisiert und entspannt
als heutzutage
[Musik]
heute agieren die angestellten an den
bahnsteigen deutlich zurückhaltender sie
achten auf ordnung und haben immer ein
freundliches wort für die fahrgäste
[Musik]
willkommen am bahnhof shinjuku vielen
dank für ihre fahrt mit uns bitte denken
sie an ihre persönlichen gegenstände
tokio japan rund 80 prozent aller
einwohner der metropole benutzen
öffentliche verkehrsmittel auf ihren
reisen durch den dschungel der megastadt
und dafür gibt es ganz pragmatische
gründe tokio ist riesig und enorm
überführt hier gibt es kaum parkplätze
darum muss der komplexe und schwer
beanspruchte öffentliche verkehr immer
und unter allen umständen reibungslos
laufen und das in einem land in dem es
regelmäßig erdbeben gibt
japan hat erleben müssen was passiert
wenn das öffentliche verkehrssystem
zusammenbricht
viele haben tragödien wie das erdbeben
von kobe im januar 1995 noch allzu
deutlich in erinnerung
damals legte das beben der stärke 7 die
gesamte infrastruktur lahm
mehr als 6000 menschen kamen ums leben
[Musik]
die tokioter leben in ständiger angst
vor erneuten schweren beben
experten zufolge wird in den nächsten 30
jahren mit 70 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit wieder ein erdbeben
dieser stärke auftreten
wenn es während der rushhour geschieht
könnte eine solche naturkatastrophe
zehntausende menschenleben fordern
[Musik]
um bestmöglich dafür gerüstet zu sein
arbeiten wissenschaftler daran die
schwachpunkte zu beseitigen
am railway technical research institute
arbeiten joschi trucker moreno und sein
team an forschungsprojekten rund um
riesige verkehrsknotenpunkte wie den
tokioter mega bahnhof shinjuku
sie suchen nach möglichkeiten um die
infrastruktur gegen künftige erdbeben zu
wappnen
wir analysieren hier welche bauten am
stärksten beschädigt werden und teilen
unsere erkenntnisse mit den bahnhöfen
muss
wir haben ein informationssystem
entwickelt
dieses teilt der bahngesellschaft um
fünf bis zehn minuten nach einem beben
via internet mit wie stark die
erschütterungen in ihrem jeweiligen
gebiet wären
anhand dieser informationen können sie
dann entsprechend reagieren
seit jahren wird hier daran gearbeitet
die auswirkungen einer naturkatastrophe
so gering wie möglich zu halten
in aufwendigen experimenten
analysieren die forscher die
gleisanlagen auf unterschiedlich schwere
beben reagieren
[Musik]
ihre erkenntnisse helfen den
bahngesellschaften sich für
entsprechende szenarien zu rüsten und
ihre anlagen widerstandsfähiger zu
machen
flexible stützpfeiler und geeignete
baumaterialien sollen verhindern dass
die nation im ernstfall zum stillstand
kommt
außerdem versorgt das institut alle
bahnhöfe des landes mit aktuellen
informationen zu relevanten tektonischen
bewegungen
sobald ein schweres beben dort wird der
schienenverkehr eingestellt
[Musik]
das vorgehen bei den erdbeben kürzlich
in kumamoto in tohoku was sehr
erfolgreich
dank unserer berechnungen gab es keine
größeren schäden an den haupt anlagen
am bahnhof shinjuku wurden unter anderem
die befestigungen der schienen angepasst
damit sie ein eventuelles beben
überstehen
hinter den kulissen des mega bahnhofs
läuft das räderwerk einer komplexen
maschine damit der verkehr nie stockt
fahrgäste wie saatchi kuba verlassen
sich darauf
alles planbare läuft dank japanische
disziplin wie quarz gesteuertes uhr beck
eine sache die sich nicht planen lässt
sind die sogenannten unfälle mit
personenschaden
japan hat die höchste suizidrate aller
industriestaaten jährlich sind es etwa
20.000 fans
erhebungen zufolge finden rund 700
dieser verzweiflungstaten allein an
bahnhöfen statt
das entspricht fast zwei fällen pro tag
aus sicht der betreiber eines wichtigen
verkehrsknotenpunktes wie dem in
shinjuku sind solche vorfälle nicht nur
tragisch sie führen auch zu verspätungen
zugausfällen chaos und damit zu
imageschäden
solche taten lassen sich nur durch
ständige aufmerksamkeit vermeiden
neben überwachungskameras gibt es im
bahnhof auch überall notruf knöpfe so
ken fahrgästen und angestellte reagieren
wenn sich jemand auffällig benimmt und
hoffentlich das schlimmste verhindern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine weitere maßnahme sind barrieren vor
den gleisen so kann kein fahrgast mehr
vor einen zug stürzen sei es absichtlich
oder unabsichtlich
die barrieren öffnen sich erst wenn die
bahn zum stehen gekommen ist
aber trotz aller technischer
vorkehrungen
das wirksamste mittel bleibt
aufmerksames personal
um sicherzustellen dass alle ihren
aufgaben nachkommen gucken erfahrene
angestellte wie vom jutta gucci im
neulingen regelmäßig auf die finger die
bahnangestellten müssen jederzeit damit
rechnen überprüft zu werden
[Musik]
ich arbeite schon seit 35 jahren für die
cyber bahngesellschaft und haare alle
bereiche hier kennengelernt sei es am
gleis oder im büro
das wichtigste ist immer die sicherheit
damit alle frage ist es sicher an bord
kommen prüfen wir verschiedene
sicherheitsaspekte
zb auf den schienen alles in ordnung ist
wir tragen verantwortung für die
sicherheit im gesamten bahnhof
der auszubildende muss jederzeit mit
einem überraschungsbesuch seines dienst
älteren kollegen rechnen
danke für ihre arbeit welche
vorkommnisse ein sehr
gut sie von den regeln
sehr gut
sarkozy ist mit der leistung des
neulings zufrieden
die überprüfungen sollen sicherstellen
dass kein angestellter von der standard
vorgehensweise abweicht auch das ist
typisch für japanische arbeitskultur
regeln werden normalerweise streng
befolgt
hier am bahnhof ist das einer der
faktoren die dazu beitragen dass die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel so pünktlich
und zuverlässig sind
[Musik]
weil alles okay
gut fahren sie weiter nach kenia
dschibuti ja
wer in japans berühmtesten bahnhof
arbeitet darf sich keine fehler erlauben
immerhin hat man es hier mit über einer
milliarde fahrgäste pro jahr zu tun
innerhalb einer stunde fahren hier 25
züge pro glas das sind eine menge
ankünfte und abfahrten
damit unter diesen voraussetzungen alles
sicher und pünktlich läuft müssen wir
einwandfreie arbeit leisten
das überprüfe ich denn es ist wichtig
dass sich die angestellten immer präzise
an die abläufe halten
die engen abfalls pläne des bahnhofs
lassen sich nur einhalten wenn jedes
detail stimmt
[Musik]
8 uhr 14
entlastung obamas zug ist auf die minute
pünktlich er und die anderen fahrgäste
ahnen nicht wie hart dafür hinter den
kulissen gearbeitet wird und genau so
soll es auch sein
[Musik]
21 stunden am tag steuern züge und busse
den bahnhof shinjuku an um 1920 wird es
noch einmal richtig voll
[Musik]
jetzt kommen an den gleisen bis zu 500
zug reisende an pro sekunde
um diesem fahrgastaufkommen gerecht zu
werden arbeiten die bahnhofs
angestellten in drei schichten pro tag
[Musik]
hilfe für passagiere umbauten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen am bahnhof shin
schoko gibt es immer viel zu tun
auch wenn die konzentration gegen
schicht ende etwas nachzulassen droht
der mega bahnhof kann nur dann
reibungslos funktionieren wenn alle hier
immer ihr bestes geben
[Musik]
um kurz vor acht neigt sich der
arbeitstag in den büros langsam dem ende
jetzt erwacht auf den partymeilen des
bezirks shinjuku das leben
die neonreklamen der zahllosen bank
clubs und restaurants locken besucher
fast zu jeder tages und nachtzeit sind
in diesem nur 18 quadratkilometer großen
bezirk bis zu eine millionen menschen
unterwegs
[Musik]
entsprechend herrscht auch im bahnhof
nach wie vor hoch betriebe
[Musik]
die meisten geschäfte schließen gegen 22
uhr
verkäuferin hasso kija madeira hat die
abendlichen rush-hour überstanden
1300 bento boxen hat sie heute verkauft
das entspricht einem tagesumsatz von
umgerechnet 7000 euro
wenn es ruhiger wird kann ich durchatmen
es ist sehr anstrengend aber es freut
mich dass wir alle passagiere für ihre
fahrt mit gutem essen versorgen
während sich für einige der feierabend
nähert steht für ein anderes team der
schicht beginn an
rund um die uhr sind 170
reinigungskräfte im einsatz der großteil
ihrer arbeit wird jedoch nachts erledigt
in guter japanischer tradition stimmen
sie sich mit einem sprechchor auf ihre
aufgabe ein
zu kollegen seien katastrophen vermeiden
vielen dank
das reinigungsteam arbeitet in kleinen
gruppen von bis zu 10 personen der
31-jährige joschi monique obayashi ist
seit sieben jahren dabei und leitet
inzwischen ein team
die teamleiter seien die arbeiten unter
den gruppen auf und koordinieren die
aufgaben innerhalb ihres teams
wie sieht euer plan für heute aus
eine gruppe kümmert sich heute um die
mittlere freifläche und den gab es
später
das team bereitet sich darauf vor dass
der letzte fahrgast im bahnhof verlässt
dann steht die reinigung der fenster und
bahnsteige an
auch das letzte kaugummi am boden muss
weg der mega bahnhof wird jeden tag
gründlich gereinigt
zwischen dem letzten zug am abend und
dem ersten zucker morgen haben wir nur
drei stunden
wir müssen schnell arbeiten
um 1 uhr 23 schließen sich die tore zum
mega bahnhof jetzt kehrt einige stunden
lang ruhe ein
[Musik]
wenn keine züge mehr an den bahnsteigen
1 fahren wird es hier ein bisschen wie
in einer geisterstadt
die überwachungskameras führten keine
menschenmassen mehr
jetzt werden all die arbeiten gemacht
von denen die fahrgäste nichts
mitbekommen
[Musik]
für joachim ohne kobayashi beginnt die
nacht mit einem seiner lieblingsshops
vor kurzem hat sein reinigungsteam einen
neuen kollegen bekommt der dabei hilft
die riesigen flächen zu säubern
einen brandneuen putzroboter
in seinem system ist der grundriss des
gesamten bahnhofs gespeichert und er
arbeitet völlig eigenständig
[Musik]
wir sitzen immer auf die neuesten
reinigungssysteme also haben wir diese
maschine angeschafft
die gibt es im ganzen land nur einmal
wir sind sehr stolz darauf
mein bester freund
eine reinigungsroboter zum besten
freunde
was will man mehr
nachts passiert hier alles auf einmal
denn für die teams ist es ein wettlauf
gegen die zeit
das zeitfenster in dem weder fahrgäste
noch züge im bahnhof unterwegs sind
beträgt schließlich nur drei stunden
unter keinen umständen dürfen reparatur
und wartungsarbeiten an den gleisen zu
störungen im zug bahn oder bus verkehr
führen das würde zu chaos führen
bevor also am morgen die ersten
fahrgäste den bahnhof betreten werden
alle spuren der arbeiten beseitigt es
ist als wäre nichts geschehen
[Musik]
derweil erledigen joschi monaco bagage
und ein team die letzten feinarbeiten
sie haben heute zehn bahnsteige
kilometer lange gänge und jede menge
fenster gereinigt wenn sie feierabend
machen muss alles blitzblank sein
[Musik]
kobayashi ist stolz darauf dazu
beizutragen dass einem weiteren
erfolgreichen tag am mega bahnhof nichts
im weg steht
[Musik]
ich hatte einen sehr guten arbeitstag
der bahnhof ist jetzt sauber die
fahrgäste können com das macht mich
glücklich
die nacht neigt sich dem ende
in wenigen minuten eröffnen sich erneut
die tore zum mega bahnhof shin schoko
und ein weiterer hektischer tag beginnt
[Musik]
in diesem riesigen bahnhof sind jeden
tag über dreieinhalb millionen fahrgäste
unterwegs
hier läuft nichts ohne perfekt
koordinierte logistik ein komplexes
orientierungssystem und hunderte von
angestellten
zahlreiche geschäfte bieten alles was
die passagiere brauchen
[Musik]
hunderte überwachungskameras erfassen
ständig jeden zentimeter des bahnhofs
und geschultes personal sorgt mit
disziplin und großem eifer dafür dass es
nicht zu unfällen kommt und der verkehr
niemals stockt
alle haben ein großes gemeinsames ziel
pünktlichkeit und perfektion am bahnhof
shinjuku